bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france 24 se considera usted un
viajero frecuente pues hizo tres viajes
en avión de larga distancia en un año un
viaje de corta duración cada mes o una
combinación de ambos es uno de ellos
obviamente este año debido a la pandemia
de ccoo y 19 los viajes en avión han
quedado reducidos al mínimo pero un
estudio hecho con datos de 2018 da una
idea de la huella ambiental que deja el
viajar en avión y quién es responsable
de la mayoría de emisiones los
resultados revelan que el 1 por ciento
de la población mundial es emisora de la
mitad de co2 causado por la aviación de
pasajeros que a su vez supone alrededor
del 2 por ciento de las emisiones
globales de dióxido de carbono este 1%
está formado por personas de un nivel
socioeconómico muy alto y que están
localizadas sobre todo en cinco países
eeuu luxemburgo singapur a arabia
saudita y canadá viajar en avión es cada
vez más accesible para muchos
algo tan sólo el 11 por ciento de la
población mundial voló en 2018 y sólo el
4% lo hizo a otro país en esta gráfica
podemos ver como la región de
asia-pacífico se lleva más del 32% de la
demanda aérea global norteamericana más
de un cuarto y europa el 23 por ciento
en cambio américa latina y medio oriente
tan sólo representan el 6 por ciento de
los viajes y áfrica el 2 el estudio pide
que se use este año de pandemia como
ejemplo para rediseñar la aviación y la
legislación ambiental y que de esta
manera la industria no vaya en dirección
contraria a la descarbonización que el
planeta necesita para frenar el
calentamiento global y el cambio
climático y de los viajes en avión
pasamos ahora a misiones espaciales
es decir brown
de esta manera el 21 de noviembre
despegaba el satélite sentinel 6 desde
california durante los próximos 5 años
este que forma parte de una misión
conjunta entre europa y eeuu hará un
mapa del 95 por ciento de la superficie
no congelada del océano cada diez días
este mapa proveerá información que
permitirá saber cómo evoluciona el nivel
del agua de mares y océanos según el
director de operaciones de la agencia
espacial europea la esa el nivel del mar
está subiendo unos 32 milímetros cada
año y se calcula que para finales del
siglo 21 el mar habrá aumentado su nivel
entre 40 y 80 centímetros una cifra que
podría ser catastrófica para millones de
personas en el mundo que viven en zonas
costeras
si lo piensas más de dos tercios del
planeta están cubiertos por los océanos
así que si observamos los niveles de
subida de los océanos
calidad estamos vigilando cómo todo el
planeta está siendo rediseñado por esta
señal que estamos causando en el clima y
por supuesto esto tiene enormes
implicaciones para la población
alrededor del mundo cientos de millones
de personas se verán afectadas por la
subida de los océanos en las próximas
décadas a medida que las marejadas por
las mareas altas que antes no tenían
importancia ahora de repente estén en tu
salón
senior de libro este problema derivado
del aumento del nivel del mar ya está
sucediendo en varios lugares del mundo
la erosión de las costas es una realidad
para muchos que están viendo cómo poco a
poco se van reduciendo o desaparecen las
playas pero no sólo es la arena la que
desaparece también con ellas se
destruyen infraestructuras costeras en
brasil según un estudio hecho en 2018
por el gobierno el problema afecta al 60
por ciento de la costa del país a está
zona a unas 5 horas al norte del río de
janeiro es un ejemplo claro nuestros
compañeros en brasilia los de augusta
lunardi nos traen la historia de este
pueblo de pescadores
es un antiguo balneario que parece un
pueblo fantasma desde hace 50 años
poderosas mareas y dunas de arena
devoran calle tras calle las casas de
estos pescadores en los últimos 34 años
celso se ha mudado 10 veces y sin duda
dentro de poco tendrá que refugiarse en
otro lugar
solía vivir más allá pero como el mar
sigue avanzando también tuvimos que ir
retrocediendo aquí también la gente ha
abandonado sus hogares
como el la mayoría de los habitantes son
pescadores y difícilmente pueden salir
al mar las presas aguas arriba del río
han reducido mucho su caudal y los
barcos pueden encajar en los bancos de
arena que se han formado
las causas de la erupción son muchas el
río cada vez más seco una urbanización
no planificada y tormentas cada vez más
frecuentes
eduardo geógrafo lleva diez años
estudiando el fenómeno propuso una
solución al ayuntamiento pero hasta
ahora no se ha hecho nada de forma
artificial podríamos bombear la arena
del río y transportarla hasta la playa
de a tafona que cumpliría así su función
de proteger el litoral el mar avanza 5
metros cada año provocando la formación
de una enorme duna de arena las
autoridades locales quieren demostrar
que están tomando medidas a pesar de los
pocos medios culpan al estado brasileño
a cargo de la gestión costera
puedes poner la arena aquí
las dunas amenazan con invadir las casas
somos conscientes de que esto no es
definitivo todavía estamos esperando una
decisión del gobierno federal pero el
estado nunca ha invertido para tratar de
salvar este pequeño pueblo de pescadores
el mar ya se ha tragado más de 500
edificios y 2.000 personas han sido
desplazadas un problema que se convierte
en un círculo vicioso de destrucción ya
que la desaparición del litoral también
se lleva consigo la protección que éste
ofrece a poblaciones costeras contra
huracanes y tormentas que como hemos
visto este año son cada vez más
numerosas más potentes y ocurren más a
menudo es todo por esta semana sigan con
más medioambiente en france 24 punto com
[Música]